yeah even look at look at this military
ai now right
it's 120 and it was so awesome to see
these dancing robots i loved it
right but one of the biggest growth
areas in robotics now
is of course autonomous weapons right
and and 2020 was like the
best marketing uh year ever for
autonomous weapons because
in both libya civil war and in
nagorno-karabakh
they made the decisive difference right
and everybody else is like watching this
oh yeah we want to build autonomous
weapons too
and in libya
you had on one hand our ally the united
arab emirates
that were flying their autonomous
weapons that they bought from china
bombing libyans and on the other side
you had our other ally turkey flying
their
drones and
they had no skin in the game any of
these other countries and of course
there was the libyans who really got
screwed
in nagorno-karabakh you had actually
again now turkey is sending drones built
by this company that was actually
founded by a guy who went to mit
aeroastro do you know that
bakarat dr yeah so mit has a direct
responsibility for
ultimately this and a lot of civilians
were killed there you know and
so because it was militarily so
effective
now now suddenly there's like a huge
push oh yeah yeah let's
go build ever more autonomy
into these these weapons and it's going
to be great
and i think actually
people who are obsessed about some sort
of future terminology scenario right now
or
should start focusing on the fact that
we have
two much more urgent threats happening
for machine learning one of them is the
whole
destruction of democracy that we've
talked about now where
where our flow of information is being
manipulated by machine learning and the
other one is
that right now you know this is the year
when the big arms race
in out of control arms race and elite
thomas weapons is going to start or
it's going to stop so you have a sense
that there is uh
like 2020 was a instrumental catalyst
for the race
of for the autonomous weapons race yeah
because it was the first year when when
they proved decisive in the battlefield
and and these ones are still not fully
autonomous mostly they're remote
controlled right
but you know we could
very quickly make things about you know
the size and cost of a smartphone
which you just put in the gps
coordinates or the face of the one you
want to kill or skin color or whatever
and it flies away and you know does it
and
the the real good reason why the u.s and
all the other superpowers should put the
kibosh on this
is the same reason we decided to put the
kibosh on bio weapons
so you know we gave the future of life
award that we can talk more about later
matthew messelston from harvard before
for convincing nixon
to ban bioweapons and i asked him how
did you do it
and he was like well i just said look
we don't want there to be a 500 weapon
of mass destruction
that even all our enemies can afford
even non-state actors and nixon was like
good point you know it's in america's
interest that the power of weapons are
all really expensive
so only we can afford them or maybe some
more stable adversaries right
nuclear weapons are like that but
bioweapons were not like that that's why
we banned them
and that's why you never hear about them
now that's why we love biology
so you have a sense that it's possible
for the big
powerhouses in terms of the the big
nations in the world to agree that
autonomous weapons is not a race we want
to be on that it doesn't end well
yeah because we we know it's just going
to end in mass proliferation and every
terrorist
ev everywhere is going to have these
super cheap weapons that they will use
against us
and it and our and our politicians have
to constantly worry about being
assassinated every time they go outdoors
by some anonymous
little mini drone you know we don't want
that and
if even if the u.s and china and
everyone else could just agree that
you can only build these weapons if they
cost at least 10 million bucks
that would that would be a huge win for
the superpowers
and frankly for everybody the um
you don't and people often push back and
say well it's so hard to prevent
cheating but hey you could say the same
about bioweapons you know
take any of your rmit colleagues in
biology
of course they could build some nasty
bioweapon if they really wanted to
but first of all they don't want to
because they think it's disgusting
because of the stigma
and second even if there's some sort of
nut case and want to
it's very likely that some other grad
students or someone would rat them out
because everyone else thinks it's so
disgusting right
and in fact we now know there was even a
fair bit of cheating on the bioweapons
ban
but none no countries used them because
they were so stigmatized
that it just wasn't worth revealing that
they had cheated
you talk about drones but you kind of
think
that drones is the remote operation
which they are
mostly yes but you're not taking the
next
intellectual step of like where does
this go
you're kind of saying the problem with
drones is that you're removing yourself
from
direct violence therefore you're not
able to sort of maintain the common
humanity required to make the proper
decision strategically
but that's the criticism as opposed to
like if this is automated
and just exactly as you said if you
automate it
and there's a race then it's going to
the technology can you get better and
better and better which means getting
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper yeah
and unlike perhaps nuclear weapons which
is connected to
resources in a way like it's hard to get
the
it's hard to engineer yeah it feels like
it's you know there's too much overlap
between the tech industry
and autonomous weapons to where you
could have smartphone type of
uh cheapness if you look at drones uh
you know it's a it's a you know for a
thousand dollars you can have an
incredible system that's able to
maintain flight autonomously for you and
take pictures and stuff
you could see that going into the
autonomous weapon space that's
um but like why is that not thought
about or discussed enough
in the public do you think you see those
dancing boston dynamics robots
and everybody has this kind of um
like as if this is like a far future
yeah they have this like fear
like oh this will be terminator in like
some
i don't know unspecified 20 30 40 years
and they don't think about well this is
like some
much less dramatic version of that is
actually happening
now it's not going to have it's not
going to be legit it's not going to be
dancing
but it's this already has the capability
to use artificial intelligence to
kill humans yeah the boston dynamics
leg robots i think the reason we imagine
them holding guns is just because you've
all seen arnold schwarzenegger right
right
that's our reference point that's pretty
useless
that's not going to be the main military
use of them they might be useful in law
enforcement
in the future and and there's a whole
debate about do you want robots showing
up at your house with guns telling you
to
who'll be perfectly obedient to whatever
dictator controls but
but let's leave that aside for a moment
and look at what's actually relevant now
so there's a spectrum of things you can
do with ai in the military and again
to put my card on the table i'm not the
pacifist i think we should
have good defense um
so for example a predator drone
is a room basically a fancy little
remote controlled airplane
right there's a human can piloting it
and the decision ultimately about
whether to kill somebody with it is made
by a human still
and this is a line i think we should
never cross
there's a current dod policy again you
have to have a human in the loop
i think algorithms should never make
life or death decisions they should be
left to humans
um now why might we cross that line
well first of all these are expensive
right so
for example when uh when
as when azerbaijan had all these drones
and armenia didn't have any they started
trying to jerry-rig
little cheap things flying around and
but then of course the armenians would
jam them
as areas would jam them and remote
control things can be jammed
that makes them inferior also there's a
bit of a time delay
between you know if we're piloting
something far away
speed of light and the human has a
reaction time as well
it would be nice to eliminate that
jamming possibility in the timeline by
having it
fully autonomous but now you might be so
then
if you do but now you might be crossing
that exact line you might program it to
just
oh yeah the air drone go hover over
this country for a while and whenever
you find someone who
is a bad guy you know kill them
now the machine is making these sort of
decisions and you and some people who
defend this
still say well that's morally fine
because we are the good guys
and we will tell it the definition of
bad guy that we think is moral
but now you'll be very naive to think
that if isis buys that same drone that
they're going to use our definition of
bad guy
maybe for them bad guy is someone
wearing a us army uniform
right or maybe maybe there will be some
weird ethnic group who decides that
someone of another ethnic group they are
the bad guys right yes the thing is
human soldiers with all our faults right
we still have some basic
wiring in us like no it's not okay to
kill kids
and civilians and thomas weapon has none
of that
it's just gonna do whatever is
programmed it's like the perfect adolf
iceman
on steroids like they told him out of
ikman you know he wanted to do this and
this than this to make the holocaust
more efficient and he was like
and off he went and did it right yeah do
we really want to make machines
that are like that like completely
amoral and we'll take the user's
definition of who's the bad guy
and do we then want to make them so
cheap that all our adversaries can have
them like
what could possibly go wrong that's the
that's i think the big argument for why
we wanna
this year really put the kibosh on this
and i i think you can tell there's a lot
of
very active debate even going on within
the u.s military and undoubtedly
in other militaries around the world
also about whether we should have some
sort of international agreement
to at least require that these weapons
have to be above a certain
size and cost you know so that
things just don't totally spiral out of
control
and finally just for your question now
but is it possible to stop it
because some people tell me oh just give
up you know
but again so so matthew messelsten again
from harvard right who
the bioweapons hero he
had exactly this criticism also with bio
weapons people were like
how can you check for sure that the
russians aren't cheating
and um he told me this
i think really ingenious insight he said
you know max
some people think you have to have
inspections and things and you have to
make sure that people
that you can catch the cheaters with a
hundred percent chance
you don't need a hundred percent you
said one percent is usually enough
because like if it's just an enemy if
it's
another big state like suppose china and
the us have signed the treaty
drawing a certain line and saying yeah
these kind of drones are okay but these
fully autonomous ones are not
now suppose you are
china and you have cheated and secretly
developed some clandestine little thing
or you're thinking about doing it you
know what's your calculation that you do
well
you're like okay what's the probability
that we're going to get caught
if the probability is 100 of course
we're not going to do it
but if the probability is five percent
that we're going to get caught then it's
going to be like a huge embarrassment
for us
and it doesn't have it's we still have
our nuclear weapons anyway so
it doesn't really make an enormous
difference in in terms of deterring
the us you know and that feels the
stigma
that you kind of establish like this
fabric this universal stigma
over the thing exactly it's very
reasonable for them to say well you know
we
probably get away with it but if we
don't then the us will know we cheated
and then they're gonna go full tilt with
their program and say look the chinese
are cheaters and that's gonna
now we have all these weapons against us
and that's bad so
the stigma alone is very very powerful
and again
look what happened with bioweapons right
it's been 50 years now
yeah when was the last time you read
about a bioterrorism attack
the only deaths i really know about with
bioweapons that have happened
when we americans managed to kill some
of our own with anthrax you know the
idiot who sent them to tom daschle and
others and letters
right and similarly the in uh
svedlovsk in the soviet union they had
some anthrax and some lab there maybe
they were cheating or who knows
and it leaked out and killed a bunch of
russians i'd say that's a pretty good
success right 50 years
just two own goals by the superpowers
and then nothing
and that's why whenever i ask anyone
what they think about biology they they
think it's great
they associate it with new cures new
diseases maybe a good vaccine
this is how i want to think about ai in
the future i want and i want others to
think about ai too
as a source of all these great solutions
to our problems
not as oh ai oh yeah
that's the reason i feel scared going
outside these days
yeah it's kind of brilliant that the
bioweapons and nuclear weapons we've
figured out
i mean of course there's still a huge
source of danger but we figured out
some way of creating rules
and social stigma over these weapons
that then
creates a stability to our whatever that
game theoretic stability is
exactly and we don't have that with ai
and you're kind of
screaming from the top of the uh the
mountain
about this that we need to find that
because uh
just like you know it's very possible
you know with future of life as you
point out uh institute uh awards
pointed out that uh you know with
nuclear weapons
we could have destroyed ourselves quite
a few times and it's um
you know it's a learning experience
that uh doesn't is very costly
you